hi I'm Alyssa Milano and this is Lucy
probably the new new outfits got that
sort of you know conservatives
appearance but then you realize that
it's completely see-through this is my
Martian she's not a dog this is my
Martian Lucy my brother's band
chloroformed days on there which I've
loved a folk singer by the name of Jose
Gonzales from the big Elliott Smith fans
Nick Drake Jeff Buckley the Beatles old
school pathology which is coming out in
from the 30th is a very dark thriller
it's about a group of medical students
that get involved in a deadly game of
who could commit the perfect murder it's
kind of sick and twisted I play Milo
Ventimiglia as fiance anytime that he
gets a little out of control and that
world he sort of looks to go into him
down 27 years this year I'm on my 16th
comeback if I wasn't an actress I think
to be the shortstop of the Los Angeles
Dodgers I probably go to 43 games a
season and that's just a Dodger Stadium
and then I also travel around I bleed
blue yes
this year was my first year that I
released touch which is my clothing line
that's in collaboration with major
league baseball it's female fan apparel
but you know was an idea born out of
necessity I go to games a lot and I got
frustrated that I could never find
anything cute that fit my body that was
fashionable or you know they made it
pink which I found horribly offensive I
just want to keep working and I'm not
one of those actors that I was like a
creative vision of my career I think the
important thing is that to do your job
she'll have to do it well be
professional and take advantage of the
opportunities
[Music]